you were the the hijab uh so starting in
2000 and for 12 years after
um so it's always whenever you're in
public you have to wear the head
covering uh can you speak to that to the
hijab maybe your mixed feelings about it
like what does it represent in its best
case what does it represent in the worst
case yeah
I think there's a lot of I've I guess
I'll first start by saying I wore it
voluntarily I was not forced to wear it
and in fact I was one of the very first
women in my family to decide to put on
the hijab and
my family thought was really odd right
like there was they were like why do you
want to put this on and and and at its
best it's it's a sign of modesty
humility
um it's like me wearing a suit people
are like why are you wearing a suit it's
a step back into some kind of tradition
or a respect for traditions of sorts so
you said because it's by choice you're
kind of free to make that choice right
to celebrate a tradition of modesty
exactly and and and I actually like made
it my own I remember I would really
match the color of my head scarf with
what I was wearing like I it was a form
of self-expression and I and at its best
I I loved
wearing it
um I think over time though
um
I don't know I've you know I have a lot
of questions around how we practice
religion and religion and you know and
and I think and I think also it was a
time where I was spending a lot of time
going back and forth between the US and
Egypt and I started meeting a lot of
people in the US who are just amazing
people very purpose-driven people who
have very strong core values but they're
not Muslim that's okay right and so that
was when I just had a lot of questions
and politically also the situation in
Egypt was when the Muslim Brotherhood
ran the country and I didn't agree with
their ideology
um it was at a time when I was going
through a divorce like it was like it
was like just the perfect storm of like
political personal conditions where I
was like this doesn't feel like me
anymore
and it took a lot of courage to take it
off because uh culturally it's not it's
okay if you don't wear it but it's
really not okay to wear it and then take
it off
but you're still so you have to do that
while still maintaining a deep core and
pride in the origins in your origin
story
totally so still being uh Egyptian still
being a Muslim right and being I think
generally like Faith driven but but
yeah but what that means changes year by
year for you it's like a personal
Journey yeah exactly